nun zu hause
happy birthday
was wird überraschen was machst du denn
hier
was mit ihr passiert inkognito unterwegs
ich wollte dann anrufen ist also immer
noch der alte markt du siehst immer noch
super aus was machst du
ich habe gleich ein geschäftstermin in
der clara schumann straße hast du vor
noch lust auf dem gipfel klar warum
nicht
wie soll ich mir da sind alle merken
hier lecker gulasch gutes essen ist das
a und o wenn du erst mal was gutes
gegessen hast sieht die welt wieder ganz
anders aus schätzle kind wenig bis jetzt
esse wo sie zwei stunden schlafen wenn
du bestes essen anbieten würdest dann
wäre der laden voll und du glücklich ich
habe dir schon ein paar mal gesagt es
reicht sich das lokal zu wechseln du
musst auch an der speisekarte arbeiten
zu meinem glück brauche ich kölsch in
sauerbraten kunden sieg vom fc und ein
bisschen von dem bringst du mir bitte
wird leuchtet frischen frisch gezapft
frischer geht's nicht und wenn du mein
gulasch nicht magst du dir selber was
holen dennoch ein paar frikadellen von
gestern
also ich habe ungefähr eine stunde zeit
also wenn es irgend etwas um die ecke
geht oder richtung clara schumann straße
und kann problem warum in der u-bahn
gibt es auch ein café mit dem besten
latte macchiato von ganz bonn
ich könnte kaum glauben wann haben sie
das letzte mal gesehen
pur ist eine ewigkeit her reese hat zwar
erzielt das zu einem festen schafft habe
ich mir nicht so vorgestellt
worum geht es bei dem termin also das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat die
medienagentur brückmann für eine
kampagne beauftragt die jugend und
ausbildung gehen die pr macht und man
selbst weil sie brauchen einen partner
der die kampagnen mit organisiert ich
dachte macht neue trends bei alex events
hör mal auch wir entwickeln uns weiter
nicht nur tun was mir gleich die dauernd
wird noch haben wir keine verbindliche
zusage du schaffst das schon
ja
hallo ich bin's komm gleich hieß es